[Music]  this bitter  [Music]  my fellow citizens of the world  what i have to say to you  is not something i was ever prepared to  say  as many of you know by now we are  suffering from inexplicable and  seemingly unrelated incidents  [Music]  ranging from power outages  to the destruction of infrastructure and  homes  [Music]  we now believe these incidents are not  unrelated  but in fact  connected  what is being visited upon our earth  contact  is not of our earth  [Music]  in an encounter was that your only  encounter  with  [Music]  we might be all it stands between life  as we know it and the end of our  existence  the world wants to test us  not today  may not be so  bitter  [Applause]  [Music]  you